[Musica]
mi occupo di geopolitica non vi annoierò
con trattati su che cosa era geopolitica
fortunatamente o sfortunatamente per noi
ma molto di moda oggi tutti se ne
occupano tutti ne parlano ma resta
disciplina quasi esoterica serve
stabilire prima che ci addentriamo nelle
mie chiacchiere di oggi la geopolitica e
lo studio dei conflitti in uno spazio
geografico detto in maniera ancora più
semplice la geopolitica non è lo studio
delle relazioni internazionali in quanto
tale ma serve a riconoscere le
costrizioni che poi obbligano gli attori
internazionali a muoversi in una certa
maniera
è una disciplina antipatica come potete
immaginare per eccellenza perché si
concentra sugli obblighi ed oggi con
questa impostazione vi parlerò di
globalizzazione
proveremo a capire che cos'è la
globalizzazione altro tema gigantesco
che va più o meno di moda c'è chi l'ama
non moltissimi chi la odia molti di più
proveremo a capire che cos'è in realtà
qual è il suo sostrato strategico per
poi intuire a che punto è quanto può
durare e soprattutto se si tratta o meno
di un fenomeno inedito sul piano
geopolitico questa che vedete alle mie
spalle quindi sono coerente con quanto
vi ho appena detto la geopolitica deve
essere sul territorio sullo spazio a
tutto ciò di cui discutiamo deve essere
cartografa bile queste sono carte della
rivista per cui lavoro la rivista limes
di geopolitica su questa carta in
particolare che vedete condizione
altisonante cioè l'impero americano
l'impero in geopolitica non ha
un'accezione positiva o negativa esiste
in quanto tale spesso anche contro la
volontà di chi ne a parte probabilmente
gli americani non volevano costruire un
impero
eppure ce l'hanno l'hanno fatto e come
sempre in questi casi se lo tengono e
moriranno da impero che sa quando gli
auguriamo molto più tardi possibile per
loro ma quella che vediamo che ci
interessa di più su questa carta e la
globalizzazione la globalizzazione è
tutta qui
se chiedessimo in italia va molto di
moda
la persona che non si occupano di
questioni strategiche di intervenire su
una questione strategica come la
globalizzazione anzitutto gli economisti
che in italia vanno particolarmente di
moda vi racconteranno che la
globalizzazione non lo so è quella
situazione quella condizione in cui gli
scambi commerciali avvengono in un unico
mercato globale
forse se volessimo condire questo
assunto con una disposizione di tipo
ideologico aggiungeremmo anche che lo
fanno perché mediamente si vogliono bene
o comunque esiste una predisposizione
tutta umana al commercio il problema è
che manca il principio di causalità e
non affermazione come questa come nasce
la globalizzazione perché esiste quanto
dura quella che vedete raffigurata su
questa carta e la divisione da parte
della marina statunitense divisione in
flotta del planisfero cioè come il
pentagono per essere molto semplici
guarda al planisfero e come lo divide in
base alle competenze delle proprie
flotte perché ed entriamo nel vivo della
questione la globalizzazione che viviamo
non è nient'altro che il controllo dei
mari e degli oceani da parte degli stati
uniti d'america proprio nient'altro
cioè nel suo telaio la globalizzazione è
tutta qui perché questo perché oggi
quindi nel 2019 non cento anni fa il 90
per cento delle merci che si muovono
sulla terra viaggiano via mare ed
evidente che chi controlla i mari su cui
viaggia il 90 per cento delle merci
quindi praticamente tutte può creare un
unico mercato globale
gli americani lo hanno fatto alla fine
della guerra fredda quando sono rimasti
per implosione o suicidio fate voi
dell'unione sovietica
l'unica superpotenza di della terra si
sono ritrovati a controllare tutti i
mari hanno pensato bene di creare un
unico mercato globale facciamo un passo
indietro
altro pregiudizio che riguarda la
globalizzazione se studiate in senso non
strategico non geopolitico e che questo
sia un fenomeno inedito cioè noi siamo
esseri umani i social network di fatto
attestano questo che crediamo di vivere
vite straordinarie altrimenti perché
fotografare il piatto di pasta
che ci mangiamo raccontare di chi ci
siamo innamorati come se fosse qualcosa
di eccezionale
allo stesso tempo siamo convinti che
anche la globalizzazione qualcosa di
necessariamente inedito lo può essere
altrimenti chi l'ha mai vista in realtà
ce ne sono state almeno un paio
precedenti all'attuale di
globalizzazione una in senso tecnico che
era la prima la pax romana la
globalizzazione originaria per
eccellenza all'epoca bastava il
mediterraneo che era di gran lunga il
mare più importante del pianeta
bastava controllare quello per creare
una globalizzazione cioè quando i romani
sconfissero alla fine della terza guerra
punica i cartaginesi e controllarono
l'intero mar mediterraneo crearono una
globalizzazione a tutti gli effetti in
senso tecnico cioè divennero dominatori
delle rotte marittime su cui viaggiano
le merci attraverso quelle crearono un
unico mercato che gestivano dopo i
romani ci sono stati britannici la prima
globalizzazione in senso geografico
strettamente geografico e quella
britannica di pax britannica per dirle
latino a caso le globalizzazioni si
chiamano con la dizione latina pax
romana pax britannica pax americana ad
indicare una continuazione quindi
l'esatto contrario di qualcosa di
inedito
invece noi crediamo tale all'epoca e
britannici controllando tutti i mari e
tutti gli oceani con la loro eccezionale
marina crearono la prima globalizzazione
della storia siamo nella seconda metà
dell'ottocento in quella che si chiama
era vittoriana per la gran bretagna
queste linee blu che vedete sulla mappa
della globalizzazione attuale non sono
altro che le rotte marittime principali
del pianeta perché le merci si muovono
sul pani spero non a casaccio
ovviamente c'è una necessità di
riduzione dei costi si deve navigare
meno per spendere meno e arrivare prima
di ci sono rotte marittime obbligate
tracciate che si seguono che sono quelle
che vedete in blu e sono queste rotte
marittime che controlla la superpotenza
tutte quante in un mondo che anche su
questo siamo umani ci sembra in pieno
caos ci sembra si capisce bene perché
per altro ma ci sembra molto pericoloso
due tre generazioni fa i nostri nonni i
nostri bisnonni film avrebbero firmato
come vivo fermerebbe ancora per vivere
questa condizione anche se noi sembra
molto spaventosa invece molto placida
specialmente alle nostre latitudini ma
se c'è qualcosa che proprio non cambia
che sappiamo l'impressione anche qui che
il mondo che viviamo in netto
cambiamento e il controllo di tutti i
mare di tutti gli oceani da parte degli
americani cioè queste primis call phoebe
le ormai da diversi decenni per che
controllano quelle rotte marittime blu
in particolare se vedete ci sono dei
cerchio lini in quelli che sono gli
stretti e gli smi del pianeta perché
ovviamente una potenza che controlla
tutti i mari e tutti gli oceani
cosa vuol dire tecnicamente a nessuno
può controllare umanamente mari ed
oceani km per quadrato km per quadrato è
impossibile vuol dire controllare quei
passaggi cogenti ineludibili che sono
gli stretti gli ismi del pianeta cioè
dove le navi devono necessariamente
passare le strettoie suez gibilterra bab
el mandeb malacca panama
né possiamo citare moltissimi ormus
tutti quegli stretti dove bisogna
passare per forza e linea di potenza
gli stati uniti possono interdire il
passaggio a qualsiasi marina che sia
commerciale un militare del pianeta
qualsiasi nessuna scusa lo strapotere
marittimo americano è inattaccabile
ancora oggi perché gli stati uniti come
nel caso di ogni globalizzazione della
storia come è successo e romani e
britannici sono una talassocrazia cioè
sono una potenza principalmente
marittima gli americani guardano il
mondo dal mare
non solo perché in modo molto violento
come tutte le grandi potenze si sono
fatti un isola sterminando sconfiggendo
le popolazioni vicine
oggi vivono di fatto su un'isola che al
nord america attaccabili soltanto dagli
oceani e quindi la loro percezione è
sempre marittima ma giudicano anche gli
altri dalla capacità o meno di stare in
mare perché così fondamentale in
qualsiasi dominio assoluto che poi
conduce alla globalizzazione avere uno
strapotere marittimo perché parliamo del
vantaggio strategico per eccellenza
innanzitutto perché le infrastrutture
marittime come potete capire per
semplice inferenza esistono in quanto
tali non devono essere costruite non
costano niente
il mare è già c'è bisogna saperlo
navigare e non è semplicissimo ci si
muore di paura mediamente specialmente
all'inizio ma esiste già
l'infrastruttura sul piano strettamente
militare controllare i mari vuol dire
poter soffocare qualsiasi nemico che si
affaccia sui mari impedire a questo di
uscire di casa di dover svolgere le
spalle al mare per terrore il terrore
del mare è un tema che riguarda tutte le
grandi civiltà e tutte le grandi potenze
non sono nella loro fase embrionale ma
che spesso ne determina il destino
i britannici come dicevamo hanno creato
la globalizzazione immediatamente
precedente a questa che finisce intorno
alla prima guerra mondiale sono
diventati potenza marittima quando non
lo erano mai stati lo diventano di fatto
nel xvi secolo a fronte di sforzi
disumani perché il passaggio da potenza
terragna potenza marittima è qualcosa di
estremamente disumano quasi crudele
all'epoca i britannici anzi meglio gli
inglesi che hanno creato la loro
capacità marittima si lanciarono sui
frutti per terrore che qualcuno
divenisse ad attaccare ancora una volta
dal continente europeo
gli attacchi sull'inghilterra
provenienti dal continente europeo sono
state una costante della storia inglese
al punto da stravolgere né la grammatica
l'invasione normanna dell'inghilterra
stravolgere la grammatica inglese
addirittura impone agli inglesi in
alcuni casi di porre l'aggettivo dopo il
sostantivo segretario generale si
dicesse che c'era rigenero in inglese
perché dal mar arrivarono i normanni che
impose una dizione francese alla
grammatica inglese che quando la
grammatica si stravolge la crudeltà e
massima di chi controlla le rotte
marittime può non soltanto creare un
mercato globale come hanno fatto gli
americani ma a dominare il pianeta
perché in sé ha fra le sue mani lo
strumento più capace anche più malvagio
di cui dispone ancora oggi quando si
discute con amenità di sciocchezze come
piazze finanziarie
oppure telematiche eccetera eccetera
le questioni che determinano l'esistenza
del pianeta sono queste sono estramente
concrete viaggiano sul
acqua quello che vediamo qui è un
tentativo di controllo bali d'azione
l'attuale tentativo di contro
globalizzazione e quindi entriamo nel
tema quanto durerà la globalizzazione
che viviamo a che punto è
piccola premessa la globalizzazione non
c'entra niente con il libero commercio
non solo perché libero commercio non
esiste non è mai esistito
eppure ideologia tutti i paesi del
pianeta da sempre applicano dazi su
qualcosa o contro qualcuno
tutti nessuno escluso chi le applica
mente proprio il perno del sistema cioè
gli stati uniti d'america in questo caso
così come i romani e britannici prima di
loro perché per creare dipendenza sugli
altri questi paesi importano
massicciamente perché importando
massicciamente rendono gli altri
dipendenti da sé e poi fisicamente
consegnano la propria moneta
nelle mani di questi a qualcuno non va
bene inevitabilmente questo qualcuno nel
tempo presente la cina che non è una
potenza marittima tantomeno una
talassocrazia che sta cercando di
sfidare gli stati uniti promuovendo una
contro globalizzazione che chiama vie
della seta
siccome la scena tutte queste cose le sa
e dal momento che la cina esporta una
buona fetta del suo pil
e lo fa per il 90 per cento delle merci
su rotte controllate dagli americani
capite che esiste sotto schiaffo degli
americani
abbiamo l'impressione che la cina sia
quasi all offensiva nei confronti degli
stati uniti specialmente in italia dove
non brilliamo esattamente per strategia
ma su questo il mare inesorabile ci dà
una cartina che ci consente di capire
quali sono i rapporti di forza
tradotto non sono i cinesi ad insidiare
gli americani nel golfo del messico ma
sono gli americani che impediscono
cinesi di arrivare a taiwan
questa è la distanza fra le due potenze
la cina pensa
attraverso questi corridoi delle vie
della seta di sfidare la globalizzazione
statunitense con la dimensione quella
principale che vedete in alto che è
soprattutto terrestre trascina intende
costruire infrastrutture che vadano
dalla sua costa la germania sulla terra
in paesi non esattamente al primato per
quanto riguarda lo sviluppo economico e
civile nell'asia centrale perché non
potendo controllare i mari prova ad
andare via terra
i rapporti di forza sono questi poi c'è
una dimensione anche marittimo nelle vie
della seta cinesi che una dimensione
utilitaristica non di sfida aperta lo
strapotere marittimo americano che oggi
come dicevo a inscalfibile ci serve a
determinare quanto durerà ancora la
globalizzazione con cui mi avvio alla
conclusione la cina anche quando pensa a
una dimensione marittima della proprio
contro globalizzazione lo fa pensando di
costruire porti nello show man indiano
che poi conducano dall'europa in
particolare al mediterraneo dove ha già
acquistato il porto del pireo ad atene e
vorrebbe mettere le mani ma ci sta
pensando seriamente a trieste in italia
che non potendo andare per mare in
quanto tale pensa di appoggiarsi come
quando si sta sulla spiaggia la sabbia
scotta si mettono i piedi ogni volta
nell'ombra di un ombrellone la cina
prova a farlo costruendo porti che le
consentano di appoggiarsi non potendo
andare nel mare aperto per non
incontrare una rappresaglia americana
che comunque arriverà probabilmente
anche soltanto su questo quindi a che
punto è la globalizzazione la
globalizzazione non si sta estinguendo
perché trump impone dazi agli altri la
globalizzazione non è il libero
commercio e il controllo delle rotte
marittime da parte di una sola potenza è
finita quando gli americani non avranno
più la capacità con la forza di
controllare tutti i mari e tutti gli
oceani nella maniera in cui ho spiegato
quando cioè visto che abbiamo introdotto
la cina che resta diciamo un peso ancora
terrestre sebbene si stia espandendo in
maniera eccezionale per quanto riguarda
i mezzi navali quando la cina sarà in
grado di interdire agli americani almeno
il controllo di un mare rivierasco
quando saranno i cinesi a balcanizzare
come si dice una parte della
globalizzazione
in quel momento la globalizzazione per
come la conosciamo finirà non sarà più
tale potrà essere una globalizzazione a
tre quarti a metà oppure semplicemente
gli stati uniti imploderanno e
lasceranno che il piani spero torni alla
fase precedente una globalizzazione che
è quella di una divisione dei mari e dei
compiti quindi tra pax diverse per
quanto riguarda l'ambito marittimo ma
ciò che ci serve ricordare che quando ci
occupiamo di globalizzazione
invece di distrarci con elementi
ideologici riguardanti il libero
commercio questione affine conviene
sempre dare uno sguardo a quello che
capita
primari che i mari ci dicono a che punto
siamo sulla globalizzazione e il dominio
del pianeta grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]